amazing story guys a part of history
they imagine this scene the story put
yourself in it and imagine this Muslim
he comes up to kiss this is like the
king of Persia what happens from there
I mean I think this is probably the the
statement that every Muslim should know
when they ask you like what's the
purpose of Islam and why did the Muslims
what's the purpose of Islam here you go
yeah what's the person why did the
Muslims spread around the world you guys
want to take money you want to do you
want to take over the world do you want
to take money do you want it that's
exactly what he asked him this last the
Sahaba and he said look I'll just give
you some money if you want money and
just forget that you even came to me you
know coming out of the desert smiling
with like camel feet and you have the
guts to come to me this is one of the
Companions of the last and final
messenger stood the mankind Prophet
Muhammad so now he's walking up the king
wants to meet him now he summons him and
now that's right and so hot a lot he
asked him this question right by the way
before that something funny they used to
have a lower entrance so that people bow
down to them
so this half entered backwards because
he doesn't bow down brother
we don't bow on it no one but the
curator yet and he was not attracted by
all the things he was walking with his
spear and disappearing everything all
the pillows you know the whole lavish
she was a long walk by the way so he can
show it's this honor so anyone would
come would come a really long walk right
so imagine he's walking in and saying
why did you come here
the king is asking him now the Sahaba
get lost I'll give you some money get
lost what he says now and this is what
Muslims have to understand why we are
here why are we trying to give Islam to
the world
it's not because we're trying to take
over so I'll go try and earn money here
at this and that she said we are come
here to take you from the worship of the
created to the worship of the Creator
here to take you from the worshipping of
the creation to the worship of the
Creator now and from the constricts of
this dunya to the vastness of the here
think about that next time you're in
traffic that's what I do the castrates
so tight and from man-made laws to the
laws of Allah that's crazy yeah that's
it
but that doesn't mean like first living
because people get all sort of
constricted idea say all what now I
don't have to follow you know the laws
of the land how would you explain it
that's not what what they're saying is
that you have to understand laws of the
land as long as I'm there under the
umbrella of the Creator you have
multiple traffic you have lots of fiscal
laws you have criminal laws and all that
universal laws you'll find any country
that is using universal laws you cannot
steal you cannot cheat you cannot you
gotta pay that yeah you signing for a
passport you're a citizen you're obeying
the rules actually it's against Islam to
disobey the rules of the land so if
you're not driving properly if you're
stealing if you're lying if you're
deceiving people whatever you're doing
that any country considers today illegal
it's illegal with it's not first that's
why it means
but when people start making things
about no this is not God God is this and
God is that and you know we should do
all kinds of weird stuff that even
anyone would be like huh anyone who has
fitrah when they hear some of the things
unless they've been brainwashed left and
right
they'll probably when they hear some of
these things like is that really from
God how many people have done that so
this is what it means very deep story
very deep but true see you next time
peace so I'm gonna go